and by the way can the casting couch
culture of Weinstein and Spacey and
Polanski and we can go on and on you
know with reaction to last night's show
Fox News contributor she lives out there
I have no idea why Tommy
Lehren you know I'm watching all this
for the little bit until home lane came
on it at 9:00 Eastern on Sunday nights
which I'd never missed and I'm sitting
there thinking nobody can tolerate this
I knew from the opening four minutes it
would be disaster ratings wise the
lowest ever well it's really perfect
what they did last night because as you
know Sean an actor is is paid a
ridiculous amount of money to pretend to
be something that they are not and all
of these individuals in this room they
do that day in and day out they pretend
to be social justice warriors and
humanitarians but really they're just
overpaid hypocrites and and they're not
funny I think that's the that's the
biggest crime here is that they're not
funny they try so hard to be funny and
they're still not funny okay how does
the crowd that just a number of years
ago literally gives the loudest applause
to a guy that drugged a 13 year old girl
and repeatedly raped her how did that
guy get the biggest applause ever and
how are we supposed to believe one word
they're saying when they applauded that
guy because I have no faith in any of
them I think they're all phonies there
is nothing more phony than the me too
and times up movement when it comes to
Hollywood it should be hashtag we all
knew it should be hashtag we all knew
and said nothing until it was trendy to
speak up I think that that's what I have
a biggest problem with is it even those
that are interviewing people on the red
carpet those that are in that room those
that are friends with people that like
you said like Weinstein they all knew or
they had a pretty good idea and they
said nothing they allowed it to continue
but now they dress in a certain color
they wear a pin they make jokes about it
and somehow they think that they're
doing the country good they think that
they're doing women good they think that
they're starting some kind of a movement
no hypocrite oh did you notice when you
pull up in the red carpet and your
beautiful Escalade with your armed
guards what did you see armed cops armed
SWAT team arms every if we're gonna if
we're going to secure the perimeter
of the Oscars can't we do that in
America school Tommy I think that what's
so great about the Second Amendment is
it protects those of us that can't
afford the luxury of armed security
details surrounding us I thought maybe
that they would do something about their
gun control message maybe they wouldn't
have armed security guards maybe that
would give them a little bit of
legitimacy but of course it's Hollywood
no that's Holly that's where you live
you choose to live there I don't know
why